pues después de una buena comida ahora
sí voy a empezar el examen número 6 la
sección número 7 que está en la página
733 y bueno creo que me falta tomar un
poco de agua pero es hora de empezar
este nuevo examen así que giacomino y
vamos a pasar por el problema número uno
por cierto o no espera que uno tan feo
en el problema número uno que dice en un
cierto juego las letras x y y ceta
tienen un valor de cinco puntos cada una
esto cada vez que estén en una palabra
si alguna vez es jugados creible o cruza
letras seguramente estás entendiendo a
qué me refiero a sé que vamos a apuntar
lo de una vez todas las letras a x las
letras x las letras z la letra q de una
palabra la letra q de una palabra todas
estas tienen un valor de 5 puntos de 5
ok mientras que todas las demás letras
en la siguiente palabra tienen un valor
de un punto y la siguiente palabra es
exquisito qué valor tiene la palabra
exquisito contando los puntos de cada
una de las letras así que voy apuntando
aquí
y exquisito que sí
y eso me recuerda a la comida que acabo
de tener esta es una y esta también es
una y ok y lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale los puntos totales de esta palabra
así que lo primero que quiero que te
fijes es que tenemos una equis aquí
tenemos una equis que vale cinco puntos
y también tenemos una cumple tenemos una
q que también vale cinco puntos y nada
más porque no tenemos z en esta palabra
ok y además me dicen que todas las demás
letras de esta palabra tienen un valor
de un punto así que pues vamos a ponerle
esta letra tiene un valor de un punto
está también de un punto un punto un
punto un punto un punto y un punto ok y
cielo me tomo la suma de cada uno de los
valores de estas letras pues me tengo
que tomar la suma de este más esté más
este más este y todos estos y cuánto es
esto bueno pues tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 12 7
1 10 son 17 puntos 17
y esta es la respuesta de este problema
17 puntos que por cierto es el inciso b
en este juego de palabras la palabra
exquisito tiene un valor de 17 puntos y
si algunas veces jugados klebold o cruza
letras esto debe de ser pan comido o muy
sencillo para ti así que vayamos al
siguiente problema pero que me cabe aquí
problema número 2 y dice lo siguiente si
2 x 2 10 y 2 x menos 10 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 20 perfecto
entonces cuánto vale x menos 5 lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale x menos 5 es lo
que queremos saber y bueno hay dos
formas para llegar a este resultado la
primera sería tomarnos de esta ecuación
a el valor de x y después sustituirlo
aquí pero se me ocurre que podemos tener
un poco más de creatividad y primero
factorizar de esta ecuación un 2 y me
quedaría
que multiplica a x menos 5 que es justo
lo que queremos lo que queremos es x 5
por eso factor hizo este 2-2 que
multiplica a x menos 5 esto es lo mismo
que 2x menos 10 esto es igual a 20 y si
ahora paso este 2 del otro lado
dividiendo me va a quedar que x 5 es lo
mismo que 20 entre 2 lo cual es 10 por
cierto esto lo que queremos x menos 5
toma un valor de 10 o la otra forma de
resolverlo que también sería bueno
recordar la sería despejar de aquí a
equis y me quedaría 2x menos 10 es
igualmente vamos a despejar el valor de
x de aquí voy a sumar 10 de ambos lados
de esta ecuación y me va a quedar que 2x
es igual a 30 y si ahora dividida entre
2 me va a quedar que x es igual a 15 y
después sustituyendo aquí 15 menos cinco
días las dos formas son rápidas para
obtener la solución de este problema
aunque a mí en lo personal prefiero la
primera forma de resolverlo porque nos
saltamos un paso y además es un poco más
elegante
ok pues vamos el siguiente problema
problema número 3 así que déjame borrar
la pantalla y vamos a trabajar en el
problema número 3 problema número 3 que
me dice lo siguiente si te representa un
entero impar entonces este es entero
entero y además es impar
de lujo cuál de los siguientes incisos
representa un entero par y bueno podemos
pensar bastante en los enteros e impares
pero qué te parece si mejor para hacerlo
de una manera mucho más sencilla le
ponemos un valor a t vamos a tomarnos un
té arbitrario y vamos a ponerle el valor
de 77 es un número entero y es impar así
que vamos a ver los incisos si nosotros
pensamos que te vale 7 y lo que queremos
es un entero para así que veamos inciso
número 1 inciso a perdón este más dos
temas dos pues esto es lo mismo que 72 y
esto es 9 y 9 es un número impar por lo
tanto el inciso a no es la respuesta
correcta inciso b
veamos 2 t menos 12 t menos 1 pues esto
lo quedaría 2 por 7 menos 1 lo cual por
cierto es 14 menos 1 es 13 y 13 es un
número impar por lo tanto tampoco es mi
respuesta correcta
y xosé a 3 - 2 3
- 2 esto lo mismo que 3 por 7 menos 2 y
esto es lo mismo que 3 por 7 3 por 7 es
21 21 2 19 y 19 también es un número
impar así que esta tampoco es mi
respuesta a b c d inciso de dice 3 t3 de
más 2 y bueno aquí lo vamos a responder
pero tres temas dos tienen la misma
lógica que el de aquí arriba si le
restamos dos o si le sumamos nosotros va
a dar un número en bar 3 por 7 + 2
es lo mismo que 21 23 23 y es impar y
vamos a ver pues si si funciona el
inciso en el inciso debe ser nuestra
respuesta correcta y dice 5 tm 5 t
menos uno más uno más uno y bueno pues
esto lo mismo que cinco por siete más 15
por 7 7 por 5 35 unos 36 y en el héctor
36 es un número par que es justo lo que
queríamos por lo tanto mi respuesta
correcta es el inciso
si tenemos a un entero impar la única
forma de volverlo par pues tenemos de
dos formas posibles o la primera es
multiplicarlo por los número par lo
multiplicamos multiplicar aplicar por un
número par ok si tenemos un momento y lo
multiplicamos por un número par lo vamos
a obtener parte o la otra es que este
número impar le sumemos un número de
para sumar sumar un número impar son las
únicas dos maneras en las cuales puedo
convertir un número impar en un número
par por lo tanto lo multiplicamos por un
número par o lo multiplicamos por un
número impar por lo tanto fíjate aquí
tenemos cinco veces este impar por
infarto le va a dar impar
recuerda que si multiplicamos por un par
de tapar pero si multiplicamos por el
impar me da impar 53 impar ya esto lo
voy a sumar otro en par y si sumamos
impar más impar recuerda que imparto
nuestro par me va a dar paz por lo tanto
es justa en mi respuesta por lo tanto
estos dos estos
y me dan un número par
número par de lujo es el programa de 13
así que vamos ser el problema número 4
volvemos todo esto de aquí y vamos a
trabajar el problema número 4 que me
dice lo siguiente yo tengo triángulos
así que vamos a hacer los triángulos
tengo un triángulo más o menos como éste
algo así ok y algo así tengo un tenemos
así estamos en el problema o no espera
cambios usted lamenta problema número 4
y también tengo otro triángulo parecido
a este algo así algo como por acá y algo
como por acá de lujo y me dan algunos
datos me dicen que este es el triángulo
a ver
y ese es el triángulo d
efe y me dicen que la distancia de
4 la distancia de a efe es 8 y la
instancia de de a efe es 9 y dice el
problema el perímetro del triángulo abc
abc este perímetro es igual al perímetro
del triángulo de ef es igual a este
perímetro ok si el triángulo a veces
equilátero eso es muy importante este
triángulo equilátero aquí
pero ok lo que me preguntan es cuál es
la longitud del lado a ver cuánto valen
esta longitud estoy aquí es justo me
pregunta lo que quiero saber es cuánto
vale este lado muy bien a lo que sé es
que los perímetros son iguales por lo
tanto eso vamos a utilizar lo cual es el
perímetro de este triángulo el perímetro
es la suma de sus lados por lo tanto el
perímetro va a ser 4 + 9 + 8 lo cual por
cierto es 4 913 más otros 21 21 de lujo
si el perímetro de este triángulo es 21
el perímetro este triángulo también va a
ser 21 porque justo eso me dice el
problema el perímetro del triángulo abc
es igual al perímetro de este ángulo df
por lo tanto este triángulo también
tiene como perímetro 21 unidades ok ya
tengo que este triángulo tiene como
perímetro 21 densidades cuánto vale esos
lados si sabemos que es equilátero bueno
pues si es equilátero sus lados miden lo
mismo por lo tanto si este lado mide x
este lado también va a medir x
y este también va a medir x por lo tanto
el perímetro sería 3 x 3 x y por otra
parte yo sé que el perímetro debe ser 21
unidades
x x mas x 3 x es lo mismo que 21
unidades que es lo que me dice que vale
el perímetro ok
3 x es igualmente 1 por lo tanto x es
igual a 21 entre 3 lo cual es 7 cada uno
de los lados de este triángulo
equilátero debe de medir 7 unidades y si
yo lo que quiero saber es el lado ave
pues ese también mide 7 unidades ya está
tenemos aquí el problema número 4 y
vamos a ser el problema número 5 así que
déjame borrar a este pesaron borramos
este pizarrón y vamos a hacer el
siguiente problema que es el problema
número 5 y tengo una gráfica de pastel
parecida a ésta así que déjame hacer
aquí
un círculo
ok y después tengo a algo más o menos
así tengo aquí el centro tengo un pedazo
de pastel parecido a este que ocupa una
cuarta parte después tengo otro pedazo
más o menos así algo algo así después
tengo otro pedazo más o menos así y
después tengo otro pedazo así y otro
pedazo así más o menos así está
biográfica de pastel y qué datos me dan
bueno lo primero es que me dicen que
este lado este pedazo de pastel es un
cuarto precisamente es 25 por ciento y
equivale a j j se llama este pedazo no
sé a qué se refiere pero ahorita vemos
aquí dice o de otros entonces voy a
poner otros y equivale a un 20 por
ciento de esta gráfica de pastel n
equivale a un 10% de energía de pastel a
m
un 15% a l un 15% también 15 por ciento
y por último acá que representa también
un 15% date cuenta que si nosotros
sumamos todos los porcentajes de aquí
obtenemos un 100% que por cierto este
pastel representa la venta de pantalones
de mezclilla en el 2011 y las letras
representan marcas aunque vamos a ver
qué me dice el problema
la gráfica siguiente representa las
ventas de pantalones de mezclilla que
vendió unas 7 a tienda en el 2011 según
sus respectivas marcas tengo la marca
acá la marca j la marca l etcétera si la
tienda vendió 900 pantalones de
mezclilla de otras marcas
es decir en otros vendimos 900
pantalones entonces esto equivale a 900
pantalones esto equivale a 900
pantalones de mezclilla cuántos
pantalones en total vendió la tienda wow
esta pregunta en la grada y creo que hay
varias formas de resolver este problema
que podremos pensar no lo podremos tener
una de tres pero se me ocurre que
podemos hacer esto otros que es el 20
por ciento de lo que vendió en total la
tienda a equivalen a 900 pantalones por
lo tanto vamos a verlo así la cantidad
total que vendió la tienda si a esto lo
multiplicamos por el 20 por ciento el 20
por ciento de la cantidad total que me
dio la tienda es igual a 900 pantalones
ok pero nosotros sabemos que el 20 por
ciento
es lo mismo que punto 20.20 porte o en
dado caso un quinto un quinto es lo
mismo que 20 por ciento por lo tanto un
quinto dt es igual a 900 pantalones por
cierto estas dos expresiones representan
lo mismo una vista porcentaje y la otra
vista en punto decimal
el 20 por ciento representa 900
pantalones entonces cuánto vale t
bueno pues vamos a multiplicar por 5
toda esta ecuación voy a multiplicar por
5 esto se cancela y me queda que t es
igual a 900 por 5 en lo cuales 4.500
4500 pantalones vendió la tienda en
total y por cierto es el insisto y así
que ya está siguiente problema no me he
quedado sin tiempo así que nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo